(gentle music)
- [Narrator] This is Camp
Lemonnier in Djibouti.
One of the hundreds of military bases
the US has overseas.
About six miles away is China's first
and only military outpost.
The two superpowers say they're
in the East African country of Djibouti
to protect their security
and economic interests.
And their presence goes far beyond here.
The US has a long
established network of bases.
Meanwhile, China has started expanding
its global military presence
at commercial ports,
which military experts say can
pose a challenge to the US.
(gentle music)
So we take a look at
what's on these bases,
and compare their strategies
as China redefines
what it means to have a
global military footprint.
(spirited upbeat music)
- [News reporter] A new
bomber base is handed over
to add to many others.
- [Narrator] Some of
America's first foreign
military bases sprung
up during World War II.
- Military base is, basically
a place where military forces
and weaponry are organized and gathered.
- [Narrator] David Vine wrote a book
about these US facilities,
and has been studying them
for more than 20 years.
- Foreign bases helped
militaries deploy their forces,
or have the ability to deploy their forces
into foreign lands.
- [News reporter] The Japanese
launched a surprise attack.
- [Narrator] After the Japanese
attack on Pearl Harbor,-
- [News reporter] Their work
had prepared one more base.
- [Narrator] the US started
a construction spree
of military bases across
the Pacific and Europe.
And when the war was over,
many American troops remained abroad.
- The US government has used its military
including military bases,
to drive its interactions
with other governments and countries.
- [Narrator] The US has treaties
with several allies
and groups of countries
such as NATO that obliged
to ensure security in those regions.
(crowd cheers)
But there's been
criticism from some locals
and those who see bases
as foreign occupation and
facilities to wage wars.
(crowd cheers)
- Our armed forces stand side by side.
- [Narrator] The Defense
Department said in a statement
that it respects its host nation partners,
and works closely and
transparently with communities.
Despite the controversy,
the US has kept a network
that allows American
troops to mobilize quickly.
For instance, following
the September 11th attacks,
the US took over Camp
Lemonnier from France,
and it became a key facility
for American troops to fight
against Al-Shabaab, Al-Qaeda's
affiliate in Somalia.
In 2018, the Pentagon said
the US had more than 500
bases around the world.
Though, some military researchers
and experts say there could be more.
China on the other hand,
doesn't have a constellation
of military bases
because for a long time,
the leadership viewed it
as a sign of imperialism.
- There had been decades of
official declaratory policy
from China that they would
never station forces overseas.
- [Narrator] Isaac Cardin
is an assistant professor
at the US Naval War College,
and he's been studying
China's maritime affairs
for more than 10 years.
- They were attempting
to position themselves
as partners of the developing world,
specifically against the Americans
who were building bases.
- [Narrator] The Beijing's policies began
to shift in the early 2010s
as China's economic
footprint began to grow.
In the first decade of this century,
the country's share in global
trade has almost tripled.
- The leadership in Beijing recognized
that the scope and intensity
of China's interests overseas
required some more military capability.
- [Narrator] One of those
places was in the Gulf of Aden,
where the rise of Somali
piracy post threats
to global shipping.
This is a route that China relies
on to ship goods between the
mainland and the Mediterranean.
So in 2016, in an effort
to counter piracy,
Beijing said it would set up in Djibouti,
what it called an army support base.
- Djibouti is probably
most effective place
for the People's Liberation Army
to start standing itself up outside
of China's immediate region.
- [Narrator] Given the mission
to facilitate sea operations,
the Chinese base is equipped differently
from Camp Lemonnier.
It's first and foremost a naval base.
So China built a pier from scratch.
Military experts say it's large enough
to host various vessels in its fleet
including aircraft carriers,
destroyers, and submarines.
The site is about 90 acres,
and military experts estimate it can host
about 2000 personnel.
Just compare that with Camp Lemonnier.
The American site is
approximately five times larger,
and can house about double the personnel.
It not only has naval support,
but also land and air
forces that can participate
in military exercises and conflicts.
And the bigger size also
means the US spends more
on paying for the location than China.
It pays the Djiboutian government
about $63 million annually
to rent the place,
according to an independent
security think tank.
While China hasn't
disclosed financial details,
a report by the US Congressional
Research Service says,
"It costs about 20 million
per year to lease the site."
Besides Camp Lemonnier,
the US has even bigger overseas spaces
that can house more than 30,000 people,
and they're usually called Little America.
- It has at least four
schools, a hospital,
fast food facilities, a giant mall,
and all the trappings of a
significant US town or city.
- [Narrator] China's
single base falls short
in terms of the size and
scope of what the US has,
but Beijing also uses a system
of more than 90 commercial ports
and terminals outside of China.
It's not unusual for
countries, including the US
to use them to dock naval vessels
for repairs and to resupply.
- What is unusual is that China is able
to use commercial
facilities that are owned
and operated mostly by
state-owned enterprises.
So the PLA has been granted some type
of preferential access to it.
- Cardin says most of the ports
are partially controlled by Chinese firms,
meaning they own or operate
one or more terminals.
But all this can still
provide a unique advantage.
- China's amassing
incredible stockpiles of data
about global trade on the basis
of its position in
commercial ports worldwide.
(jet whooshes)
- Cardin says this insight
alongside a military presence
can be a powerful combination
that could challenge
the US and its allies.
- When you consider
that China's potentially
in a position to deny,
or delay, or disrupt,
or even control vital shipments,
so ultimately this network puts them
in a position where they
have some coercive leverage.
(bell rings)
- [Narrator] For now,
military experts say China
isn't pursuing an extensive
network like the US.
The concerns have been growing
among some American officials
that Beijing could be planning new Bases.
- They are seeking, actively
seeking a military base
on the Atlantic coast of Africa.
The place where they've
actually made progress
toward this is equatorial Guinea.
(gentle music)
- [Narrator] China's defense
ministry didn't respond
to a request for comment on
its base plans in Africa,
or whether Beijing could
use commercial ports
to counter other countries.
The US Defense Department
said it's concerned
about the lack of transparency
and clarity around Beijing's negotiations
with host nations.
So as the US and China
compete for global influence,
the networks that they build
and maintain could become one
of their most essential military assets.
(gentle music)